the apollo astronauts took a photograph
of our earth as it rose above the moon
our earth is like a perfect blue marble
floating in the black void of space
and i just thought i'll make planets
we're ready for takeoff are you guys set
ready
i'd love to see different
geology and flood plains and desert it
takes me away i love
to explore
when somebody holds one of my planets in
their hands i want you to imagine
what it might be like to crawl into that
little world
and orbit around it and to imagine what
life might be like there
but i also i don't want you to
find out everything about it at first
glance
[Music]
glass is
the most amazing material
it's an alchemic blend of sand and
metallic oxides combined with
extraordinary blinding heat
the result is this amazing material that
flows and drips like honey
when it's hot
glass is alive
and it has this
inner light and transcendent radiant
heat that make it
simultaneously
one of the most fascinating
and one of the most insanely frustrating
materials for an artist to work with
it's a process of building up layer
after layer from the inside to the
outside
just a little the most gentle whisper
will blow it out
[Music]
there's no way of mastered glass
i've done it for almost 50 years and
i am constantly surprised
[Music]
i decided to start hiding my planets
because
i was digging around in the flower beds
in the fall and i found
several handmade marbles
they were just as bright and beautiful
as the day they went missing when kids
probably were called in for supper maybe
70 or 80 years before
they sort of transcend age and religion
and culture
maybe they can transcend time
the planet that i hide now will be just
as fascinating to somebody
50 years or 500 years from now
as i began to travel i always put a
couple of planets in my bag with me and
actually if you go to my website you can
propose a place where you'd like to hide
an infinity planet
and people have sent back wonderful
photos of places that bin
places that put planets
i like the idea that it's a gift i like
the idea that maybe it will be found and
somebody will wonder what it is
there are at least 3 000 or more planets
hidden around the world
some of them are in truly exotic and
hard to reach areas and some of them are
in totally mundane places where you
might just see them walking along and
looking down
at an old tree
[Music]